come here baby I'm struggling Shepard I  really don't get that much time off but  when I do like spending with my family  and how about golf girl you gotta slam  it there you go  go ahead family means everything to me I  don't get much time to hang out with  them with football being such a priority  you gotta be kind of on your toes at all  times  same thing with football bye-bye  I mean go out there by yourself  sometimes it's always quiet on the golf  course you don't really hear much  screaming or anything like that and it's  one of those sports is just so  challenging and I'm such a competitor  that I'm like I'm gonna master this  okay sterling here's the game we have  for you three on the thousand three on  the Cowboys three times I'm gonna give  me three shot  right do it that's hard I mean you  always got to be perfecting your craft  and so you have to be in the fine  details all the time at least I got one  [Music]